so now they're talking about doing their
they're gonna come out with a two-faced
movie because you know the Joker movie
was such a success that the movie
studios are saying well what other
Batman villain can we do a whole movie
about but I'm really worried about this
because remember the media promised us
that with the Joker movie there would be
copycat Joker's people that were so
inspired by the stories of a psychotic
mass-murdering clown that they would say
to themselves you know I would like to
be a psychotic mass murderer in Clark
that didn't end up happening fortunately
but I would be concerned about copycat
to faces that that could really happen
what if the film inspires copycats who
go and burn half their face off and
decide to make decisions based on coin
flips from here on out it that is a real
concern at least it is a concern that
the media will will insist is a concern
at the very least now what I what I want
to start with today is this LGBTQ I see
a PG and GF MBA that's really the full
acronym by the way Town Hall that was
last night with the Democrats on CNN but
the thing with the LGBTQ I see a PG ngf
MBA Town Hall is that it was in my view
a disaster for the Democrats an
unmitigated glorious if you're not a
Democrat disaster and not just in my
view because I'm a crazy right winger of
course they don't care about my view
they don't care what I think but they
should care what normal sane moderate
adults think of which I am none of those
things but those who are in that
category they shouldn't because you need
that you need to win at least some of
the people in that category which is a
dwindling category I admit but you need
to win some of them if you want to win
the White House and and Democrats made
that harder on themselves last night
essentially what they decided to do was
to take their weirdest wackiest craziest
most bizarre most extreme most cultish
beliefs and put them on display for four
hours and I imagine that every every non
leftist who watched the townhall or
probably more likely watch it is see
some of the clips today they all have
this expression while they're watching
it it's a it's gonna be something like
that's more and more when you when you
hear Democrats talk especially when you
give them time to really get into their
views that's the extent that's the
expression of like 70% of the American
population it's just that kind of thing
so we're gonna get into this we will get
into the wild and wacky side of Democrat
politics but first a word from light
stream who doesn't want less stress in
their life
if high interest credit card bills are
adding to your stress then I've got a
real solution for you
pay off your credit card balances and
save money with a credit card
consolidation loan from my friends at
lifestream you get a rate as low as a
five point five nine that is five point
nine five percent APR with auto pay
which is much lower than the national
average interest rate which could be up
to twenty percent so this is much lower
than that plus here's a good thing and
it gives you some peace of mind that the
rate is fixed so you know that it's not
going to rise it's not going to jump on
you it's fixed and that's what it is the
online application is quick it's easy
you can apply right from your phone so
you're saving money it's it's it's easy
to get peace of mind here's here's some
more benefits just for my listeners you
can apply now to get a special interest
rate discount the only way to get this
discount is to go to light stream comm
slash Walsh L IG HT STR e km dot-com
slash Walsh subject to credit approval
rates include point five percent auto
pay discount terms and conditions apply
and offers our subject to change without
notice visit like stream comm slash
walls for more information okay so the
LGBTQI CIP GN g FM be a town hall i
confess that i didn't watch it myself
football was on so I had a choice you
know I could I could watch Democrats
pander to the gay lobby for four hours
or I could watch football tough decision
ultimately I decided to go with the
sports option so I like most people and
catching catching the highlights today
and the highlights really play more like
a blooper reel and now it didn't have to
be this way okay
keep in mind that the Democrats like it
or not the Democrats have absolutely won
when it comes to gay rights gay marriage
everything in that vein they've won so
in theory you know to do a town hall on
these issues as a Democrat could be a
good move it's a good play could be
because if you spend the whole time
talking about love is love you know
marriage equality that kind of thing if
you just if you just pander about that
sort of stuff for four hours keep it in
that Lane I think it would be a win for
the Democrats because again whether you
agree with or not the polling is very
clear most Americans either support gay
marriage or just don't care but remember
that the goal of the left is to
fundamentally transform society - to
change it change our core values change
our culture but they're kind of like the
Joker and the other Joker the dark
knight remember where he said he's like
a dog chasing a car he wouldn't know
what to do if he caught the car and
that's kind of what the the left is like
they they caught the car in many
respects and they didn't know what to do
next
so they just go off chasing a different
car the drive to change to transform on
the left is never satiated
it never ends I think in some ways it's
appropriate that we call them
progressive even though I wouldn't call
this progress personally it is
progressive the sense it's always just
moving they have no they have no real
vision for a society that they want to
build and establish they just always
want to change and keep changing even if
they even if they're going back and
undoing their own advances in their own
victories it doesn't matter it's just
always tearing things down and
rebuilding that's always what it is on
the left
they can't rest on their laurels they
have to go further always further and
further and further even on the gay
marriage issue they want to push more
radically to the left they could if they
knew it was good for him they would just
leave it alone they would say okay
one that one gay people could get
married all across the country
hooray good for us that's a victory for
us and you just and leave it there
that's it but they can't so here for
example is better O'Rourke
mr. pander the great the giant panda
bear advocating that churches lose their
tax-exempt status if they don't abandon
biblical marriage this is from your
LGBTQ plan and here's what your rights
as a quote freedom of religion is a
fundamental right but it should not be
used to discriminate do you think
religious institutions like colleges
churches charities should they lose
their tax-exempt status if they oppose
same-sex marriage yes
there can be no reward no benefit no tax
break for anyone or in any institution
any organization in America that denies
the full human rights and the full civil
rights of every single one of us and so
as president we're going to make that a
priority and we are going to stop those
who are infringing upon the human rights
of our fellow Americans that is a really
great way to take a wedding issue and
turn it into a loser if you're a
Democrat most people in America are fine
with gay marriage but they're not fine
with penalizing churches over it because
most people in America also are fans of
religious liberty and it's on a side
from the constitutional issues and
everything the attack on on on religion
and faith it's also from it again from a
Democrat perspective it's so completely
unnecessary just to go and start trying
to force this on churches and everything
although I've been warning all along
that they will start doing that of
course they're gonna do it because they
can't help themselves it's it's
unnecessary because most churches are
abandoning their their beliefs about
traditional marriage anyway
so so if you're if you're a liberal you
could just sit back for another ten
years ten years from now there might not
be any churches left not because of any
forcing but just the church is on their
own are abandoning biblical teachings on
marriage just like they're abandoning
biblical teaching teaching on on every
other subject but again they can't help
themselves also here's another way to
make it a losing issue for yourself as a
Democrat by approaching it like this and
a supporter approaches you and says
senator I'm old-fashioned and my faith
teaches me that marriage is between one
man and one woman what is your response
well I'm gonna assume it's a guy who
said that and I'm gonna save them just
marry one woman
assuming you can find one
first of all notice how worn in in order
to make this snide comment in order to
insult her ideological opponents she
first has to stipulate that the
hypothetical person she's insulting is a
man though I'm going to assume this is a
man why are you assuming that there are
just as many conservative Christian
women as there are men this is something
they love Democrats love doing this
where they like to pretend that all of
the positions they detest all of the
ideas they abhor are held only by men
they always are pretending that the
people they're opposing are just men and
considering these are the people always
accusing others of erasing them you're
erasing me I'm being erased in fact we
have an example of that just from this
town hall we'll play in a second but
they really are erasing conservative
women they just if you're a conservative
woman it's the Democrats they just
pretend you don't exist pro-lifers there
are so many pro-life women in fact there
are more pro-life women than men at
least active in the movement movement
and anyone who's you go to March for
life you go to a you know the pregnancy
center you go to a any kind of pro-life
fundraising banquet I've been to all
these things many times and it's going
to be heavily women it's going to be you
know 70 percent women but the way that
the Left approaches the abortion issue
they pretend that all pro-lifers are men
they just if you're a pro-life woman
they just they're not even going to
engage with you they're going to pretend
you don't exist but that's what she does
here so so that's why that you know but
but which here's the question for
Elizabeth Warren would you respond that
way to a woman would you say hey you're
free to marry a man if you could find
one you ugly cow because that of course
is the implication of her insult when
she says the the if you can find one
thing is another way of calling
conservative men unattractive
unappealing and I'm just wondering if
she would insult a woman like that the
answer is no she's just going to pretend
the woman doesn't exist but it's on the
issue of transgender
that the Democrats really took the
insanity of their ideology put it on on
a parade float and marched it around
town pointing to it and going hey
everybody look at this we're crazy look
at our craziness I've got a bunch of
clips to play in that vein let's start
with this because I love it this this is
a this one I actually enjoyed and Cuomo
got himself in trouble for this of
course but but I thought it was great
and my pronouns are she her and hers she
her her mine too
all right all right first so Cuomo Cuomo
apologized immediately of course he came
back like a like a whipped dog with his
tail between his legs
she I'm sorry for my inappropriate
outburst but his joke was entirely
appropriate okay it is manifestly
ridiculous for people to go around
giving their pronouns the only
appropriate way to respond to something
like that is mockery there really is no
other way to respond to it it is
unserious it is silly it's ridiculous
and the only thing you can do with a
ridiculous silly unserious thing is mock
it is laugh at it you can tell Cuomo's
reaction there was just it was
instinctive it's it's unless you've been
until you've been conditioned every
every normal person you know when when
someone comes up to them and introduces
themselves with their pronouns any
normal person is gonna respond like okay
you're responding with a smirk a laugh
something it's just a normal reaction
because that's such a silly ridiculous
thing to do it has to be but you have to
be conditioned the left is trying to
condition that normal reaction out of
you and that's why they focus so much on
kids because they realize that adults
who have grown up as sane people and
have lived that way for 30 40 50 years
it's gonna be really hard to condition
you now to be insane but you can do it
with kids it's a lot easier to condition
kids and that's why they focus so much
on kids and that's what makes it so
insidious and evil and we'll talk more
about that in a moment but Kamala Harris
introduces herself with pronouns when
did she start doing that well 12 seconds
ago she spent she's 54 years old she
spent 54 years of her life saying hi I'm
Camilla and now suddenly she's got a
whole speech about her pronouns to
accompany her introduction and this is a
theme this is a theme that came up again
and again these candidates are mostly in
their 50s 60s you know
Sanders is of course 107 buddy jizz is
14 but but you know most of them are in
their 50s and 60s and so they went
through their whole adult lives up until
approximately yesterday believing that
men are men women are women believing
that men have penises women have vaginas
believing that you know you can't change
your sex by mutilating your Jenna your
genitals further whole lives they
believe that even the most radical left
among them you're not gonna find clips
of Elizabeth Warren 20 years ago or 30
years ago suggesting that actually women
can have penises you're not gonna find
that for their whole lives they just
like everybody else in in the history of
humankind has believed in the basics of
human biology and then suddenly they've
abandoned biology and adopted this
gender Theory superstition but they
can't explain why you know they can't
explain what prompted them to decide
overnight that oh no actually men can
have but vaginas right here's a here's a
great example of this dynamic watch this
so senator quick follow speak to your
evolution on this in the 2012 campaign
for Senate you criticized the judge's
ruling that granted transition-related
surgery I'm a transgender inmate you
said I don't think it's a good use of
taxpayer dollars right do you regret
that yep no it's a bad answer and I
think it's a bad answer and I believe
that everyone is entitled to medical
care and medical care that they need and
that includes people who are transgender
who it is the time for them to have
gender affirming surgery I just think
that's important and the appropriate
medical care so a few years ago she held
the very logical and correct position
that taxpayer shouldn't have to fund
genital mutilation of course they
shouldn't that is not health care that's
not a treatment okay a treatment a a
medical
treatment it is a legitimate medical
treatment when somebody has an illness
or a disorder or a disease of some kind
and the treatment is is the point of the
treatment is to is to cure or treat or
manage that disorder illness or disease
if you're a man and you have a
functioning penis that is not a disorder
that is not a disease that is not an
illness that is exactly how it should be
everything is in working order you're
good to go physically so it cannot
possibly be legitimate health care or
medical treatment to mutilate a healthy
functioning part of your body obviously
now Elizabeth Warren has believed that
her whole life until now she changed her
mind why well she can't explain because
her new position is completely ludicrous
it is completely without a scientific or
moral foundation she is pretending to
have gone insane on this issue and
that's why it's so awkward to what watch
it and they all are none of these people
I mean these are all basically saying
for the most part basically intelligent
adults they understand biology they
understand but they're pretending they
don't in fact
is a question I love for someone ask
these candidates though nobody will but
but here's the question very basic
here's what you should ask them when did
you decide that men can have vaginas and
what prompted that change please explain
that okay youyou believed that that men
have penises your whole life that's what
you believed just recently you decided
otherwise why was there some sort of
scientific breakthrough was there some
sort of discovery that was well no okay
well then what was it did you slip and
hit your head I mean explain this shift
in thinking talk about flip flops you've
got these people they that's a pretty
significant flip-flop they have flipped
on human biology they've decided 60
years into their lives oh you know what
biology isn't a thing it turns out I
think they should have to explain that I
would love to hear an explanation now as
as as we have discussed the left's
embracing of transgenderism has and I've
talked about this many times the left's
embracing of transgenderism has rendered
so many of their other positions
incoherent obsolete moot and last night
demonstrated that very clearly because
you had various points where arrogant
aggressive men got up and started
lecturing or silencing women which is
usually something if you want if you
want to set left this off if you want to
if you want to really upset them then
all you have to do as a man is do is do
or say anything that could remotely be
construed as criticizing or silencing a
woman but and and usually they're so
extreme about it that that that could
even include even just just being a man
and offering your opinion to a woman is
usually enough to be accused of
silencing a woman but when it happened
last night at various different points
it was not only
tolerated but applauded because the men
who were doing the silencing and the
lecturing happened to be wearing women's
clothes
here's one example watch in next
secretary Castro I want to bring in Shay
diamond a singer-songwriter from Los
Angeles she currently supports mayor
bootie judge Shay what's your question
um it's Shia diamonds she put that on
record it's all thank you yes honey it's
violence to miss gender or to alter a
name of a trans person so there's always
get that right first talk about
mansplaining this guy just accused the
female anchor of violence for
mispronouncing his name violence is
violence to mispronounce his name that
was insulting aggressive pompous
arrogant all of the things that
feminists hate in men all of the things
that they find in us even even if they
aren't really present yet here is a
perfect example of it and they had no
choice but to applaud you you've got a
man sitting there like honey that's
violence calling her honey I mean I
don't look if that's not mansplaining
then I don't know what mansplaining is
even more striking example look at this
just want to take a moment before I ask
my question to validate the pain of our
transgender siblings that demonstrated
earlier and that have spoken up today
[Applause]
let me tell you something black trans
women are being killed in this country
and seeing it you ever race black trans
women for the last time let me tell you
something black trans women are dying
our lives matter I must extraordinary
black trans woman
okay think about what you just witnessed
there a dude stole the microphone from a
woman and started screaming about how
he's being silenced and marginalized a
woman of color by the way no less so he
stole the microphone from a woman and
and and started screaming he took her
time he took her spotlight her
microphone made it all about himself
this is like a Kanye West Taylor Swift
moment and this is one thing that you
know in these in these men who are who
are identifying as women I think one one
thing you often find is in enormous
arrogance and a total disregard for
women for how women feel for their
perspectives their own safety their
their privacy all of that these men
throw all that out the window they say I
don't care
shut up that's their message to women is
shut the hell up I'm gonna do what I
want you you know your place stand in a
corner shut up that's what these men are
saying to women constantly I mean if a
woman says you know I really feel
uncomfortable if you come in into our
locker room and it shut up you're not
allowed to say that you big it and in
feminists and most feminists not all
there are a few brave exceptions but
feminists and liberals you know when
they see this that in their heads
they're recoiling and and they're pissed
off about it but they're too afraid to
speak up they're too afraid to upset
these guys and this is a another example
he steals a microphone all this talk
about silencing women is that not
silencing of what we didn't just do that
and tries to make it about himself there
meanwhile they're doing a whole townhall
they're doing a four-hour townhall about
LGBTQ I see a PG and GF MBA issues and
that's not good enough for this guy oh
because it's not specifically about him
it this needs to be specifically about
me not this woman no not those me me
this is all about me by the way the
thing he said about trans people being
murdered he mentioned that I think in
his in his little rant there and that's
that's true the trans people are
murdered at a disproportionate rate but
it is manifest nonsense it's a claim or
insinuate that these murders are hate
crimes so every time you hear this about
the the transit transgender people are
dying they're being killed yeah all
that's true it's tragic it's terrible
but anyone who claims that it's some
sort of hate crime epidemic they are
lying they are liars they are despicable
disgusting liars
who are exploiting real-life tragedy and
death and lying about it for political
gain they are scumbags for doing that
because in reality the reason why
there's a disproportionate murder rate
among transgenders this is a tis this is
just the fact is because there's also a
disproportionate amount of prostitution
and drug use a vastly disproportionate
amount of prostitution drug use among
transgenders and so they are in those
dangerous high-risk situations and
they're more likely to be killed that's
that's that's why and it's a tragic
thing it's a horrible thing it's
something we should be talking about why
is it and that these people are ending
up in these high-risk high-risk
situations why is it let's talk about it
let's get to the bottom of it let's try
to actually save some lives
but when you sit there as so many
Democrats do and just you don't care
about the lives you don't care about
life and death you think it doesn't mean
anything to you these people died you
couldn't care less it's just it is a
statistic that you can throw at your
opponents in an argument and lie about
it and I'm disgusted by it
just as I'm disgusted by people you know
who make everything about themselves all
right and finally speaking of being
disgusted I I saved this clip for the
end because it makes me so angry you
know you know how I am with this kind of
stuff well I have maybe you might say I
have I have a pet peeve about child
abuse I don't know what it is but I'm
just I'm not a fan of child abuse I
really don't like it I hate it actually
and so when I see child abuse it it
makes me really angry and then when I
see a bunch of adults literally giving
child abuse a standing ovation that
makes me that just sends me over the
edge and so I'm gonna play this for you
and then I will try to as calmly as
possible offer a little bit of analysis
of it here it is thanks Jacob in Ireland
nine-year-old transgender American my
question is
what were you doing your first week as
president to make sure that kids like me
feel safer in schools and what do you
think schools need to do better to make
sure that I don't have to worry about
anything but my homework oh I like that
question
now that mom there she's apparently a
radical leftist with the human rights
campaign crazy coincidence isn't it
crazy how these radical leftist parents
who are proponents of the left's insane
gender theory it seems like they're
often the ones who end up with
transgender kids okay just say it's
crazy how does it happen to such a
coincidence it just so happens it's
almost like this is conditioning you
know it's almost like if a child grows
up in a household where he has not given
any direction she I should say in this
case with this child or she is not given
any direction and she is not and nobody
explains to her what it actually means
to be a girl or be a boy if she grows up
in a household where this gender Theory
nonsense is is his stuff down her throat
she's gonna end up transgender I mean
that's it's almost like conditioning I
don't know it's almost like these
parents are conditioning their kids to
have gender confusion so that they the
parents can parade their children around
like fashion statements saying look at
me look how woke I am my own kid is
transgender look look it's horrifying it
really is that young girl and and she is
a girl she is being abused this is
psychological and emotional abuse of the
worst kind because you're depriving her
of a childhood you're depriving her of
an identity you are forcing her to have
an identity crisis as I have said a
million times and I'll say a million
more times even if it was possible to
choose your own gender which it isn't
but even if it was a child
could not possibly make that choice
because they don't even know what a girl
or a boy is they don't know what those
words mean and if you don't explain it
to them as a parent they're never going
to know and they also have no concept of
the consequences of their actions they
cannot see beyond the nose on their face
they can't look into the 20 years in the
future and ask themselves you know do is
this really something that I want a
nine-year-old girl is not capable of
saying of thinking about a lifetime
living as a man whatever that means and
and and the implications of that at how
that's going to affect her downline she
just she can't even formulate those
kinds of thoughts this is why I a very
simple question could be asked when a
when a young girl says I feel like a boy
all you have to ask her is what is a boy
that is that's it's not a gotcha
question that's that has to be the most
natural follow-up question and it amazes
me that you could have a quote
transgender child and you've had this
conversation so many times and you've
never asked that another way of putting
it
your daughter says I feel like I'm a boy
or I'm a boy
what do you mean daughter what what do
you mean what are you trying to say what
is a boy to you in your mind what do you
think a boy is and I guarantee their
answer is going to be because they are
innocent children they are innocent
naive children as all children are and
so when a young child who's a young girl
says I think I'm a boy what she means is
I I am
I find the things that I associate with
boyhood to be appealing ie superheroes
trucks you know wearing is wearing jeans
I mean these these these these these
kinds of things playing going out and
rolling around the grass playing sports
that's what she's really saying she's
saying I would like to I I am interested
in these kinds of things that are
traditionally masculine now she doesn't
have the language for that or the
thought process for it she doesn't
understand her own thought process
because she's a child and so that's
where you as a parent have to interpret
her thoughts for her because she doesn't
understand what she's talking about
because she's a child I do this all the
time with my kids
all the time my kids are not not with
gender issues but all the time my kids
are you know saying that they want
something or you know in and I know as a
parent that's not really what they want
because I know them and I'm their parent
I'm the adult
and so I'm stepping in and saying no you
don't it's not that's not really what
you want this is what you want over here
and then they go oh oh oh right yeah
even if it's something is simply you're
at a restaurant and there are five items
on the kids menu and and you know you
show and you give those options to your
six-year-old and if this happens my kids
all the time they'll say oh yeah okay I
want the I want the hamburger and I'll
say no you don't really want the
hamburger because we've we've you know
you've gotten hamburger three other
times you don't finish it you don't like
it that much I think what you really
want is the hotdog and then they'll say
oh yo yes daddy I want the hotdog
because they don't know now if a child
can't even make a decision can't even
rely doesn't even know really what they
want on them on the kids menu you think
they can make a decision about what
gender they are
if your nine-year-old girl wants to play
with trucks and wants to roll around in
the grass and wants the throat throw
football and wants to play with
superheroes great let her fantastic
nothing wrong with that okay this was
supposed to be what the left wanted
before they decided that oh actually we
can all just change genders back and
forth back and forth before that it was
all about you know expanding these these
notions of masculinity and femininity
and saying that hey we don't have to put
a girl in a box and force her to wear
frilly outfits and play with dolls if
she issued she wants to do you know
things that are more traditionally
associated with boys great and and the
thing is that argument I agree with that
yes because because ideas of masculinity
and femininity are partially social
constructs that's true there are places
in the world where it is masculine for
men to wear garments that look sort of
like dresses there are places in the
world where that's the case and then in
our country it's not so so there is some
of it is cultural
that's true but boy and girl these are
biological categories they are not
social constructs so a statement like
girls should act this way X Y Z that
statement is going to be informed by
culture and tradition and it is going to
be subjective for the most part but a
statement like girls have you know
female reproductive organs that is not a
subjective statement that is a statement
of objective fact and it's the case no
matter where in history the girl is
located no matter where on the map she
is located
alright let's see here's um okay well a
couple things before we before we wrap
up for the week first I saw an article
yesterday about this Sesame Street has
introduced a new Muppet named Carly
here's here's Carly take a look at her I
don't know who the girl is there I guess
some Sesame Street character I don't
know but Carly
this puppet Carly has a mother addicted
to opioids yes really she I mean that is
a hell of a dark backstory for a Sesame
Street Muppet isn't it now I know that
gritty origin stories are all the rage
these days but geez I like like what's
that there's got to be limits and I get
that opioid addiction is a huge problem
I'm not making light of it and and
that's what the Sesame Street people are
saying that you know we want opioid
addictions huge problem the country
there are kids that are sadly tragically
growing up with with parents who are
dick addicted and so this is supposed to
help them deal with that I just I don't
know if this is the best forum for
addressing that problem I think that
there are there are a lot of very
serious issues that kids deal with sadly
not all of them lend themselves to
puppets that's just that's my thought I
don't know I'm interested to know how
you guys feel about that finally there's
a report circulating that aoc alexander
of kaiser cortez the avowed socialist
the champion of the working class spent
like 300 bucks on a haircut and i only
know about this because I saw the
articles claiming that conservatives are
outraged by aoc spending 300 bucks on a
haircut I have actually seen any
outraged conservative so this I suspect
this is another one of those things
where it is um there's a bunch of
leftist outraged at right-wingers for
being outraged about something that
we're not really outraged about I think
that's probably what it is
I didn't even know that it was a thing
to be outraged about until I read
articles claiming that I was already
outraged about it now I don't really
care how much you spends on a
a haircut I do think it's always gonna
be a little ironic a little hypocritical
hypocritical anytime a privileged
left-wing socialist goes out and treats
themselves to a nice luxury like that
it's not a problem for anyone else to do
it like I said I don't care how much you
spend on a haircut but when your whole
thing your whole mission in life is to
shame rich people then yeah your own
spending is gonna come under scrutiny I
think that's fair that's you brought
that on yourself but putting that to the
side
here's really the only reason I'm
talking about this the only reason this
caught my eye is I have been informed
that actually three hundred dollars for
a woman's cut if it includes coloring
apparently is a normal price that's what
I've been told not just by left wingers
trying to make an excuse for alc but
even in fact my friend Allie Stuckey on
Twitter said that it's it's it's normal
this is perfectly normal amount for a
woman to spend on this and that
horrified me to learn because my wife
often goes to the salon to get her hair
did and and I know she gets it colored
and I never asked how much she's
spending my haircuts are like 18 bucks
and so I always assumed that she's
spending something similar to that now
the fact that her cuts take nine and a
half hours to do I you know made me a
little suspicious but but 300 my god in
heaven
three hundred dollars how am I not
homeless how are we not starving with
those kind of prices how much should
when she goes to get pedicures how much
is she spending five thousand dollars I
mean what was she came home the other
day with with some new makeup did she
mortgage our house for the lipstick I
don't even know I now I'm I just I I
never really thought about how much this
stuff costs for women here so here's my
thought I've got an anniversary coming
up and please nobody spoil this for her
okay I'm sharing this with you as the
audience and I just say please don't
spoil it because whenever I talk about
my wife on this show one of her friends
it never fails one of her friends always
text her to let her know that
talking about her my wife doesn't watch
the show so so but but her friends do
I guess because she has her friends
monitoring it and so they'll always text
guess what your husband talked about
today
guess what story your husband told so
all I'm asking for you snitches out
there okay you spies just don't tell her
this one because this is supposed to be
a surprise
here's my thought anniversary is coming
up eight years of marriage 8 blessed
years and apparently you know six and a
half million dollars of haircuts it
would seem in that time I'm thinking
that my gift will be a coupon that I'll
give her for free haircuts and pedicures
for life done by me and that'd be pretty
romantic wouldn't it I am I am
volunteering to take over haircut duty
I've got I've got scissors I've got a
pair of clippers I've got a comb
homemade is always better that's my
thing
it's the thought that counts how
difficult can it really be to to cut a
woman's hair especially it's like long
hair my wife's got you know like
shoulder length so just just it's all
you gotta do is just go in and cut it
she wants the color it just slap some
shoe polish on there or whatever you
know what however the color the hair and
and you're good to go you're fine
alright that's what my my anniversary
card is going to say and we'll leave it
there thanks everybody for watching hope
you have a great weekend Godspeed
Matt Walsh show is produced by Robert
Sterling associate producer alexia
Garcia Del Rio executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer his Austin
Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright Philly wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there